beh quello che io propongo è che donna
ambiente innovazione sia un triangolo
che favorisce il cambiamento
questa sono io filmetto dieci anni fa
però avevo anche dieci chili in più
quindi insomma siamo pari
se ti capita di essere eletta presidente
nazionale di legambiente la più grande
associazione ambientalista italiana
sai che il rischio di essere anche solo
una bandiera è dietro l'angolo e quindi
io ho deciso fin dal primo giorno di
fare due cose innanzitutto di fidarmi
della mia associazione che mi stava
dando una straordinaria occasione e poi
di fidarmi del mio istinto e di cercare
di interpretare questo ruolo non appunto
come un ruolo ma mettendo al centro il
cuore che è un tema importante
ecco io penso che quello che possiamo
affermare anche e soprattutto come donne
che c'è una dignità nel ricoprire un
ruolo di potere con una dignità pari
appunto tra il sentire e il pensare le
donne hanno menti eccellenti ma la
capacità di sentire di entrare in
empatia di sapere che cosa ci si aspetta
di cogliere la realtà che ci circonda
ecco io penso che questo possa essere
una chiave in più una chiave importante
a cui dare dignità e attenzione
e allora anche l'ambientalismo può
accogliere questo questo nuovo modo di
guardare la realtà odio l'ambientalismo
sì che un brand antico eppure l'ambiente
è un terreno privilegiato di innovazione
ormai tutti si occupano di qualità
dell'aria di qualità del cibo del
territorio parliamo di rischio
idrogeologico in un paese in cui i
maschi diventavano adulti con l'acquisto
dell'automobile
parliamo di car sharing di mobilità
dolce quella che ti fa scoprire il
territorio senza consumarlo
parliamo di dieta mediterranea abbiamo
visto crescere il consumo del biologico
del 25 per cento nel 2015 e quindi
tantissime cose stanno cambiando
l'ambientalismo l'ambiente non è più un
argomento per poche elite
ma invece un sentire comune anche fonte
di partecipazione di mobilitazione
territoriale e questo sì questo sì che è
una straordinaria novità ma per favorire
questo cambiamento né dobbiamo sapere
interpretare le relazioni che
incontriamo e anche cogliere il bisogno
di cambiamento è un po come nella nobile
arte dell'aikido questa non sono io
perché io sono un terzo chiude una
maestra da ma insomma tempo al tempo
anch'io oro la cama i pantaloni neri
nella iii kido si dice che l'avversario
comunque la persona che pratica con noi
non va affrontata di petto ma bisogna
sfruttare entrare nel suo cerchio e
sfruttarne la potenza
ecco è esattamente questo cogliere il
centro degli altri il punto di vista
dell'altro e da questo punto di vista
noi donne abbiamo un potere privilegiato
e l'ambiente è uno strumento di
cambiamento un luogo privilegiato del
cambiamento per le cose anche che prima
dicevo io sono una donna ma sono donne
anche il presidente nazionale del vvf il
presidente dell'istituto nazionale di
urbanistica la vicepresidente di slow
food la vice presidente di italia nostra
questo perché le donne hanno capito da
tempo che l'ambiente è un luogo del
cambiamento ma lo è se sia la capacità
io credo di appunto mettere insieme
l'innovazione la qualità ambientale la
relazione dico io è l'essere donna
e allora vi racconto come io ho provato
a interpretare fin da subito questo
triangolo magico tra queste tre parole
che creano un flusso e ve lo dico
attraverso due episodi
questa purtroppo una immagine che noi
conosciamo bene il 24 agosto alle 3 34
del mattino un terremoto nel centro tra
l'italia devasta matrice ma anche centri
di arquata sono tantissimi comuni
coinvolti 3 34 intorno alle 9 il mio
cellulare inizia a squillare i
giornalisti alcuni giornalisti insomma
non decine
mi chiedono interviste dichiarazioni via
radio in televisione io rifiuto di
apparire non perché sono timida ma
perché penso che in questo momento c'è
bisogno di memoria sicuramente c'è
bisogno che una forza come la lega
ambiente dia il proprio contributo in
termini di spiegazione del fenomeno di
quello che è successo perché quelle case
si sono frantumate ma che possono farle
8 momento un geologo che il nostro
responsabile scientifico è un architetto
che il nostro vicepresidente nazionale
quindi io faccio un passo indietro
decido di coniugare la memoria la forza
delle memorie dell'associazione con la
dignità del pudore con la dignità del
pudore memoria e pudore il 10 settembre
sono state ospite dei giovani
industriali lo sono stata all'interno
del circuito di misano adriatico mentre
erano in corso le prove del gp in moto
c'era anche valentino rossi abbiamo
fatto un dibattito sul sull'economia
circolari hanno creato un nuovo format
mente poteva intervenire in un minuto e
trenta gr il giro di pista perché poi
passavano le moto non si sentiva niente
l'ho trovato il geniale molto divertente
io credo che l'altro fronte importante
di rinnovamento sia la voglia di
dialogare e di confrontarsi anche di
lasciarsi contaminare di soprattutto
dialogare con chi è diverso da noi
guardate questo è assolutamente
necessario capire il punto di vista
dell'altro non per assumerlo in maniera
critica ma per capire qual è appunto il
punto di vista diverso su una stessa
questione dialogo e contaminazione come
potete immaginare queste due scelte
hanno avuto molti apprezzamenti ma ho
ricevuto anche delle critiche feroci
ecco io credo che invece noi donne
abbiamo un punto privilegiato in cui
partecipare al cambiamento e questo è il
mio modo di dare il contributo
un contributo che passa appunto per la
capacità di mettersi in discussione di
incontrare il diverso
di non essere limitate della propria
sensibilità ma anzi usarla come forza di
cambiamento
tutto a posto allora no assolutamente no
questi sono due poverini non vi lasciate
ingannare dalle facce astute sono due
poverini si chiamano simone samuele la
loro mamma viaggia tantissimo a un
lavoro che l'appassiona spesso è assente
li affida ad altri loro sono i miei
bambini naturalmente ma che fine hanno
fatto i tuoi figli poverini dove sono
poverini questa è la domanda che le
donne che lavorano si sentono ripetere
più spesso
ecco io penso che loro facciano parte
della mia forza ne fanno parte loro ma
ne fanno parte tutti i bambini perché
quando uno si occupa di ambiente di
qualità ambientale guarda tantissima le
generazioni future e che loro non
possano e non debbano essere un limite
ma invece come dire una forza motrice
che ci spinge in avanti ea partecipare
credo che da questo punto di vista il
contributo delle donne sia eccezionale
ma io vi voglio raccontare altre quattro
storie io qui con me oggi ho portato
altre quattro donne caso mai non avesse
non fosse riuscita a convincervi sono
quattro donne straordinarie e vi dico
commentare credono questo triangolo del
cambiamento lei a daniela ducato è un
imprenditrice sarda di guspini e ha
scoperto che i residui della lavorazione
agricola vino uova ma anche lana sono
straordinarie risorse da mettere a
disposizione quindi con la lana ci si fa
efficienza energetica in edilizia si fa
bioedilizia con il vino si colorano le
pareti questa donna ha creato un impero
economico e daniela dice due cose
secondo me molto interessanti
innanzitutto la contaminazione tra le
arti lei ha avuto questa idea
leggendo il diario del giovane regista
tornatore che in viaggio in sicilia
raccontava all'autosufficienza di
un'azienda agricola racconta
appunto la capacità in agricoltura di
riutilizzare gli scarti agricoli e di
rimetterli in circolazione e poi da una
poesia che parla di farfalle è una
poesia di gattuso che dice appunto
nell'innovazione strutturazione di una
di una farfalla ha trovato l'idea per un
nuovo materiale credo che sia importante
questo concetto di compenetrazione e poi
daniele ha creato la casa verde che è
una un network di 75 aziende che fanno
innovazione in edilizia e condividono i
saperi condividono i saperi è un modo
per procedere tutti insieme lei e
filomena pucci filomena sostiene che il
segreto è fare della propria passione la
propria impresa e ha raccolto la storia
di 80 donne che in italia sono diventate
imprenditrice credendo nelle proprie
passioni e trasformandolo in business
lei e giusi nicolini è il sindaco di
lampedusa e linosa è stata prima
direttrice della riserva naturale
orientata di lampedusa dove convive
turismo di massa e nidificazione delle
tartarughe ma questa piccola donna molto
molto dura molto concreta e anche la
persona che affronta sulle proprie coste
sulla costa della propria isola lo
sbarco di migliaia e migliaia di
migranti lo fa in una solitudine
vergognosa e giusy ha detto nel corso di
ultimo dopo subito subito dopo uno degli
ultimi naufragi questi morti sono i miei
morti perché nessuno rivendicava quei
corpi e lei giustamente pretendeva le
condoglianze di tutti perché lei invece
assumeva su di sé il dovere
dell'ospitalità è anche il racconto di
quella tragedia che stava accadendo
settimana prossima giusy sarà a parigi
insieme alla sindaca di parigi all'opera
per chiedere all'europa di aprire un
corridoio umanitario e soprattutto
finalmente di occuparsi di questa
questione non come un'emergenza ma
leggendo un processo in atto la storia
va avanti e il cambiamento non può
essere fermato
infine catia bastioli questa donna
ragazzi ha inventato l'alternativa alla
plastica quando voi andate a fare la
spesa
adesso usate il sacchetto in mater bi e
lei che l'ha inventato è il polimero
alternativo alla plastica ha creato un
impero che alla novamont ad essa anche
presidente di terna lei è una scienziata
che ha saputo utilizzare che ha saputo
essere anche manager e anche
straordinaria comunicatrice prima si
parlava dei saperi che si si intrecciano
no interpretare più ruoli e più funzioni
ecco queste quattro donne io credo che
abbiano interpretata al pieno e molto
meglio di me sicuramente questo
triangolo questo triangolo magico ma io
credo che anche nell'ambiente lismo ci
possa essere questo tipo di cambiamento
se si parla di cura di empatia di
partecipazione basta con l'ambientalismo
che si limita a conservare e bene invece
che l'ambientalismo scenda in campo che
sappia accompagnare il cambiamento
mettersi in gioco metterci la faccia
entrare nelle contraddizioni piccola
provocazione questa e venezia sono
sicuro che se quando hanno posato la
prima pietra ci fosse stata
un'associazione ambientalista avremmo
assistito alla difesa di quella
straordinaria zona umida cercando di
impedire la costruzione di questo ecco
io penso che quello che noi possiamo
fare è abbandonare una concezione di
ambientalismo classico e invece
sviluppare un'ecologia delle relazioni
non so se troppo innovativo ma io so che
ogni tradizione è un'innovazione che ha
avuto successo
quindi ho grande speranza
[Applauso]